what happens when you get your community
to pay sixty dollars to develop a map
around eight months ago dice la ask
battle fielders what kind of map would
you like to co-develop in battlefield 4
many in the community said build us an
urban map dice la said no let's get a
little bit more specific can't be an
urban map can't have levolution and then
directed people to their high level
framework requirements page on reddit oh
and also if you want to work on this map
pay us up to sixty dollars on top of the
base game buy a premium membership in
all fairness premium membership is
primarily for the five DLC packs for
Battlefield 4 assuming you didn't
pre-order in which case you already had
China rising and probably double paid
for it I'm happy to say then that the
result of the community paying to
develop and beta test the community
operations map with dice la turned out
pretty great the operation outbreak map
launched this week free to the public
outside of CTE and delivers very jungle
terrain reminiscent of bad company two
underground tunnels a central waterfall
feature to gawk at and great balance
between inventory and vehicle combat on
top of that at this stage battlefield 4
has a staggering number of weapons and
toys to play with one toy the phantom
bow is now easy for everybody to get and
can be picked up from this crate in the
center of the map it's been very
interesting watching guys continue to
support battlefield 4 which launched in
october 2013 and has seen continuous
development with dlc the night maps
project and bug fixes galore it's my
impression both personally and speaking
with devs that ea's hedging its bets
with battlefield 4 because it hasn't
continued to throw its weight behind the
newer visceral developed battlefield
hardline in 2015 III press conference eh
didn't even bother to cover hard lines
new criminal activity DLC during their
stage ship hardline still has a large
following on console through small to
medium size infantry base maps but the
PC community didn't get the larger Maps
and vehicle based combat they've come to
expect in a battlefield title and
largely abandon it so it seems dice la
will continue to throw resources into
battlefield 4 until the next battlefield
title confirm for 2016 sees the light of
day it is a bit of a missed opportunity
because this map would have been a
perfect Colombian style drug map for
hardline so if you're still a huge
battlefield
been waiting for the next major
battlefield title head on over and
download the free community operations
map you'll have a lot of fun and will
probably think those who spend up to
sixty dollars to help dice la created